[Music]
just how many people
are dying from kovid 19. as it stands
more than one and a half million people
have died of kovid19 around the world
but official figures can only tell one
part of the story
that's why scientists are calling for
certain types of data to be used to get
more reliable numbers
to help us better understand mortality
in the coronavirus pandemic
[Music]
first off we take you to the russian
city of ufa
where the discrepancy between the
official coronavirus death toll
and how many more deaths there are
compared to last year
is too wide to ignore
with a steady stream of coronavirus dead
speed is of the essence at the morgue
every morning the team from the funeral
agency ufarutual
comes here to collect new victims of the
pandemic
twenty-nine-year-old artur kinsey kev
has been working in the funeral business
for 12 years
but he says he's never had to bury this
many bodies
one time there was a huge line of
hearses standing in line outside the
morgue
it was only then that people started to
understand the death had really come
call the relatives to identify the body
this morgue in the city of ufa is only
for people who died of coronavirus or
had contact with an infected person
the bodies have to be sealed in plastic
the coffins closed
many russians feel their dead should be
treated with more respect arturo
explains
their relatives are often more tense
than usual because they're dead or
handed over to them in plastic body bags
they aren't allowed to open the bags i
tell them that right away
some people cry and demand that we open
the bags
then i have to explain that they could
get infected themselves
this virus is no joke
has been in the business for seven years
today he's in charge of the team of
undertakers
he says since the second wave of
coronavirus there have been at least
twice as many deaths in the city of ufar
funeral agencies have had a tough time
keeping up
we have more work a lot more work
over a million people live in ufa the
capital of the republic of
government statistics say that only
around 90 people in the region have died
of the coronavirus since the pandemic
began
but the official numbers also show that
during that time over 4 000 more people
died than last year
coronavirus infections are spiking
across russia
but authorities insist the situation is
under control
the undertakers aren't so sure today
yuri kozlov and his team
are entering a 92 year old woman she
didn't die of the coronavirus
that means her relatives can say their
final farewell with an open casket
which is the tradition in russia
usually funerals are big family affairs
in russia
but the pandemic has changed that people
are often worried about getting infected
and stay away so far no one in yuri's
team has caught covid he can only hope
it will stay that way in russia people
say if it's decided up there
that you'll get run over by a street car
you won't drown
fate
the next day the team prepares for four
more funerals
artur and his colleagues hardly have
time to worry about their own health
at the moment they're just too busy
la sylvester guard joins us now he's the
project coordinator of
euromomo that of course stands for
european mortality monitoring
welcome to you we've just seen a new
daily record of coronavirus related
deaths here in germany totaling
590. why do you think that number has
gone up so sharply considering we're in
the second wave
uh i think the most what we're seeing is
uh
now a very widespread
transmission of kobe 19 in germany and
in
many other european countries that is
now reflected also in
rapidly increasing covet mortality
but how do you think the numbers will
develop further have we already
seen the peak that's a really good
question
so if you look at the what we
experienced in the first
wave in in march in europe we saw a very
rapid
increase in mortality within a few weeks
and a very rapid decline
after the lockdowns then we saw a very
acquired period during the summer in
most european countries
but since around september october
in europe many countries have seen
gradually increasing
transmission not only in small focal
areas but widespread in the country and
this is now reflecting in a gradually
increasing excess
mortality and we're not sure yet when
this will peak
exactly exactly we can hope that with
the
increased restrictions we are now having
in many
countries in europe we will also see in
our
decline again in mortality but we're not
sure yet
can you please clarify for our viewers
what exactly is meant by
excess mortality
yeah so excess mortality is uh
more death than you would expect
normally from
previous years of of mortality so you
you calculate the
the expected average based on previous
numbers
and you can adjust for seasonal
variations and then you see the
difference from what you observe
in the current time current week
and you compare what would you expect
and that is what you define as the
excess mortality
and under situations when you have
public health events that
that excess mortality you can achieve it
to that
event which is now covered 19 and we
don't have actually other
public health events or explanations
that could explain this
mortality so what we see is really a
true picture of the total
mortality from cove 19 in europe
now we've borrowed a graph from your
organization showing deaths in europe
from 2017 to 2020. we're noticing in
particular
two market peaks one from a severe flu
season in 2018 and one in the first wave
of the coronavirus earlier this year
this means coronavirus is definitely
deadlier than the fluid doesn't it
how deadly is it exactly according to
your data
yeah certainly we see normally
during the influenza season in europe we
see excess mortality
and the example you show is from a very
bad
flu season in 1718 which was
quite bad but the the peak we saw
in the first wave of kovic 19 are many
times higher
the multiplicity is is many times higher
than in the worst souffle
infringer season we have seen so it's
particularly the group of
65 years and above uh it has it
it is at least fought four times worse
than in
the bad 17-18 season and
it is more than 20 times worse than
the might influence the seasons so it's
very significant
extra mortality we see during kobe 19
compared to a normal
influencer season now the pandemic has
gone on for the better part of a year
we've
all changed our behavior in a way to
prevent more covid19
deaths we're all wearing masks and
social distancing
has that had any impact on the number of
deaths for other infectious illnesses
like the flu yeah i
i certainly we have seen a very dramatic
decline
in in other respiratory infections
uh influenza and as an example in
denmark we have seen a
steep decline in meningitis cases so
that will also reduce mortality from
those other infections
thank you dr lasse westergard he's the
project coordinator of
euromomo or european mortality
monitoring
we appreciate your analysis today thanks
very much
welcome
up next our science correspondent derek
williams answers one of the questions
you've sent in
[Music]
what is the distinction between a
vaccine's efficacy and its effectiveness
every branch of science has its own
vocabulary and these two words
from pharmacology have been used
confusingly
and often interchangeably in the last
few months although they mean
different things for the general public
efficacy is is the less familiar term it
describes
how well a drug or a vaccine works
in a controlled environment that's been
designed
to give clear answers that's because in
the best of all possible worlds an
independent team should be able to take
an efficacy study
conduct the trial in the same way and
reach
the same results so so trials like the
covet 19
vaccine candidate trials will have some
baseline parameters
for example they do things like exclude
test subjects with pre-existing medical
conditions
the fundamental questions are does the
candidate work
in healthy people safely in the doses
that we're administering
and if so does it also appear to protect
at least those groups of people from
contracting
a disease effectiveness on the other
hand describes
how the same vaccine will perform
when it's released into the wild if you
will out there in the real world
when it's given to people on a much
wider scale
this aspect of vaccine performance is
also
monitored of course after approval is
granted
but data takes a lot more time to gather
and to study effectiveness numbers for
covet 19 vaccines will almost
certainly vary from the efficacy numbers
we've been hearing about lately
in the news they'll be different in
people
in different age groups for example and
although
we're optimistic that current candidates
will
indeed protect a high percentage of
people
in the general public who received them
don't forget
that calculating both efficacy and and
effectiveness
requires a sort of statistical slight of
hand
because after all you're trying to
figure out
how many people didn't get a disease
because they received a vaccine or or to
flip that idea on its head
what might have happened had they not
been vaccinated and
and that's a pretty slippery concept
[Music]